hello everyone Welcome to our third
design review of the day preparing for
version
14 um this is continuation of our
discussion about calculus and
algebra and um let's see where are we
going to start we going to start um I
follow up with finite Fields I I don't
have the revised names there for you you
came up we came up with new names Adam
what so it's finite field index without
elements and to finite field without
coefficients yep so and from finite
field and so on yeah okay but we also
had graphic design changes for the
appearance of a finite field element
right right okay are those do we have
those yet or not
yet you
don't I haven't received anything from
uh uh from Jeremy yet I thought he was
my understanding was he was going to
send something to me if if I'm mistaken
I will follow up and who who's pming
here Avery I'm I'm here okay so if you
can try and connect those pieces just
make sure that something comes together
thanks um all right I think we're on to
Matrix operations is that correct we had
we talked about
um uh we talked about some of this right
last time yes these are the N versions
basically of the S versions We
introduced last
time okay so do we we didn't talk about
the structured Matrix stuff last time is
that correct no just a little bit okay
do we want to talk about that here or is
it we don't necessarily need to I as I
said I think we have
another round to go before it's all kind
of filled in
but let me ask a question about about
things like symmetric Matrix okay so so
if I'm
um uh me pull this up do I need to go to
the um well here let's let's Source
yeah
uh if you want to see the documentation
of it or something no no I'm I'm
understand but I mean if I just say
symmetric
Matrix what's the
input just a symmetric Matrix I mean
that's one of them but you could also
have ragged kind of thing where you ask
it to fill
up okay so if I say table of range of I
I up to five or something that will be a
ragged creature yes right okay if you do
normal of that you can or Matrix form it
will it will have symmetrized it yes
okay so now
this oh now I'm confused here so well it
promoted a vector to a matrix right oh
no you did range sorry I yeah never
mind
uh well so if I say
I I guess my question here is
this
I'm still I keep on thinking about
little tabby things to um and maybe it's
a wrong
thinking where some kind of raft could
offer conversion of that object that
that's is that a bad idea is that silly
idea I'm just trying to get some way
that that we don't feel like people
don't feel like oh there's 700 data
types now and I don't know how to get
from here to there I mean if I go from
this
go ahead and I and I say orthogonal
Matrix you mean like the summary box had
like a little little thing in it you
could click like normal basically yep
exactly but I mean if I do
this
spfo why didn't that work because it's
not an orthogonal
Matrix right I mean what's an example
one that is that that where like any
rotation Matrix for instance would be
orthogonal any permutation Mak okay fine
fine but I mean if I say but what I want
to do is I want to
get uh what I'm looking for is is can I
do this by the way that the message text
not found is obviously a bug right yes
yes I got it yes um but my question is
just this will work if the thing is
right do do herian Matrix of symmetric
Matrix I mean it'll be a trivial herian
Matrix but all
right
magnificent
okay I mean the one question I have is
sort of you
know what's the relationship between
symmetric Matrix and the symmetrized
array of you know of rank two and the
same
symmetry yeah what is the difference and
if you say symmetric Matrix or symmetric
array will it
convert better yeah should symmetrized
array right is that correct
guys I'm not sure we gone as far as
array we've tried to stay within the
Matrix I mean Roger's idea was that we
should try and promote the Matrix side I
mean this can be done you know just
means that symmetrized array needs to
recognize this and know what to
do and you know it's just another input
form for symmetrized array yeah yeah
right that seems reasonable to me go
ahead
I'm just saying that we didn't go down
we've St tried to stay in The Matrix
world because that do that you can't do
that sorry don't understand your
preferences I I no I understand it's
just a question of I mean what we could
I mean we've done so far so okay it may
not be the highest priority but I don't
think it's right to no absolutely no
yeah we looking for stuff to so so here
what we you know there's more things
that need to be you know the the many
more structured matrices generated that
are not yet sort of promoted to that
type so for instance when you do
correlation that that will be a
symmetric Matrix
always the correlation Matrix is always
you know a symmetric
Matrix right I have a question here when
we say Target structure r or whatever
surely we should Support also and maybe
you do surely we should also
support you know unitary Matrix
uh right because the fact that all these
Target structures are in fact
types yeah I mean I think the most
useful thing is automatic though but
it's
okay yeah so well in this case it's
probably not going to why is it not work
well I like what it did now for goodness
sake we don't change that yeah but we've
done it for mat you know where
sufficient large size where you have
yeah fine issu but here our thought is
we don't change stuff we want to give a
kind of language for going into the new
world but I think that what you said
earlier on about unit but we need
another symbolic value then that where
you don't have to specify which
type so automatic but not
automatic well maybe it's an
all yeah maybe that's that's
it yeah but uh I mean right we we have
used right dense sparse and
structured yeah those are big classes of
things but structured is is like
um it's like a whole family of
structures right I mean exactly right
but it it sort of choose well I I would
hope that what it means is you know
choose the most sensible structure for
this oh yeah Str yeah but we had
structured I'm sorry we have string
structured and that is what I was
looking for that's what what what is the
most
useful hopefully that
should right I mean right the problem I
mean we could I supposed to support
arbitrary heads but but the well that's
clearly a bug um yeah I think this
should just so this should just give
back uh the most natur I guess it should
give back a structured array um no it
should should give back an orthogonal
Matrix so that because the natural
associate over here yes yeah so this
automatically picks which structured yes
that's fine this is easy enough to do
that's fine okay let's talk about the
workflow that people actually want here
okay one of the great features of our
system is that you don't have to know
7,000 different data types so the fact
that this just comes back as a list is a
huge win let's say I didn't I don't know
I I I think for for small things it
might be useful to have the explicit
list I had finished I hadn't finished I
had finished
okay the workflow is for the things that
you do interactively in in you know
fractions of a second you just don't
want all of the
structure okay but then a typical
workflow is now let's scale it up now
let's do the case with you know a
million million by million Matrix or
something okay for which if it tried to
blow it out this way it would blow
everything up as we all know so what I'm
trying to understand is what's kind of
the the methodology so so for example
you know when we print things out we're
talking about this with graphs as well I
hope we're going to get that with graphs
soon of elision we have that with just
printouts we have that with with data
sets we have that with there was another
thing we were just talking about doing
that with um uh where you know when it
gets too big we Eli it in some way where
it's rather easy if you wanted to you
know you press the forget the allision
button okay and so what I'm the thing
I'm coming to
is and that's why I was sort of talking
about rafts and so on let's imagine that
what came out here was a thing I mean
just like the the it isn't quite like
the too big thing but it might be might
be we could make it that so that if the
thing well like like like okay let's
take iconized for example okay let's say
we were going to produce and something
we haven't thought about yet but we
could is something where when there's a
big
output in instead of just giving you
know that that we Auto ionize certain
pieces of it because it's not useful and
it's going to blow out the front end to
try and print it am I making
sense yes so what I'm what I'm kind of
thinking of here is what if there was
something that's kind of like icon eyes
so here's what I think that the the
future I would like to do for this which
we not ready to tackle yet is that we'll
basically have a matrix type and I will
absorb sparse and structured and so on
as internal structure to it then it can
always print even if it's a million bym
million Matrix but you're not going to
look at every entry In A Million by
million Matrix it will show you 10 with
elision stuff things that they can
actually show on
screen we could also do other things to
kind of summarize the you know the over
overall structure even though you see
kind of a an Alli you know partly
printed out but also Allied but it's
never going to super stress any part of
the
system because you didn't actually
format that big thing and and then El
light it you
you right I understand but but I mean so
for example sparse array has been I
would say fairly successful at being a
you can treat it like the like the array
that's that it represents type thing
yeah most operations part and flatten
and I don't know if flatten Works does
flatten work on sparer Rise probably
does
probably
does I actually would have to check the
spay work on sorry what's the question
does flatten work on Spar arays oh of
course it
does oh yeah nice okay but
so I guess as it does on any of the
structure Rays I mean you might lose the
structure but it'll still
work right so if you if if you if you
flatten you know percent 13 or whatever
that is that symmetrized array right it
won't be a symmetrized array anymore or
or that one I well that one would
because it's a symmetrized array but uh
you know if you had a symmetric Matrix
and you flattened it it's not a matrix
anymore
obviously I my question
is when is sparse array promoted I mean
do all functions that work on lists also
work on sparse arrays answer no
correct
and does
that cause a problem I mean like for
example if I say column of percent 16
oops I'm sure it's going to work yeah oh
okay so an interesting question and an
interesting study would be to see what
sparse array does and doesn't work
on you know we we've had it in the
system now what 15 years more than that
more than that yeah closer to
20 gosh how time
flies
um so my point
is you
know that's a case where and we've had
obviously packed arrays internally
for longer than that right um yes
version
four
okay
uh so I
mean I'm just trying to understand how
you know packed arrays sparse arrays
whatever this is not a thing we have to
discuss right now because because what's
happening in this version seems fine for
this version and you know it's a it's a
it's like data structure it's one of
these optimizations that the cogn Senti
will know about and others will
not
yeah but as I said the long term ASM
totically I think that all of these
things sparse arrays structured arrays
you know other arrays will be part of a
you know an array
structure that because if we just took
we tried this exercise in one of these
design reviews where we had this
discussion a c year or two
ago people want them to be displayed as
matrices but people use lists of lists
for other things than matrices and they
might be fairly upset if we always typ
it's a typical problem that exists in
the um graph stuff graph uses
traditional form which is something we
should fix by the way that this issue
that if you give a matrix or list of
lists as a label for a graph it will
show as a matrix which is often not you
want right yeah we we run some sometimes
into that same issue with wolf from
alpha notebook Edition which defaults to
traditional
form right right well right and so your
you're saying is if we had a matrix
wrapper we could or array wrapper of
some kind we could tag that yeah and
then then it would be
reliable
and relable I mean there are operations
where it will reconstitute a list of
lists but that reconstituted thing will
be um
uh uh what am I trying to say will will
um
uh right I you know won't reform and the
same there's no it's it's like graphs
and other things it's like what or or
colors on you know when you do a graph
Union of two graphs and they have
annotations on them what do you do with
the anotations type thing it's the same
thing
here yeah but I think if we have that
sort of eventual sort of object then the
flows the
workflows
will just be kind of one level simpler
there's so much more automation that we
can do along the way
yeah all right um okay what else do we
need to look at with
these I just want to talk for a couple
comments that you know right I mean the
reason some functions don't understand
you know sparse array or these structur
things right is because people literally
write rules you know down values for
blank list instead of you know blank
question mark Matrix Q um in what in the
internal code in well yes or their own
code right you know users are writing
packages right you
know um yeah but we need to deal with
that I mean we need to deal with that we
need to have some way of doing which
again is not you know we've done it with
p and we and we do have right we have
dysfunction developer list
representation CU right which gives true
for lists and pack arrays and sparse
arrays and structured arays so all of
these things
will you know so people should be
writing things correctly and w't and and
they're not and they won't they won't
they won't it's not a bridge we can get
them to go over
um sander on our live stream asks rather
sensibly why is there no Matrix wrapper
that basically doesn't do anything
except for formatting it's called Matrix
form well Matrix form needs a all of
those things need a lot of modernization
work yes there is no
such uh first of all that needs a lot of
modernization there's a lot of features
that I think people want and they want
it to hang around the Matrix not just
one one know but I I know but this
that's the point I mean if we had a
transparent thing that you know if
Matrix form if every operation that
dealt with matrixes ate a matrix formed
Matrix that would already be progress
yes yes definitely that is I don't
really see any harm in these things
eating eating a matrix formed
Matrix it I I see harm I mean what
what's a thing that takes a matrix I
mean part people use part to operate on
a matrix but we can't make part treat
Matrix form specially well you're
proposing to I mean part does treat Spar
aray
specially uh well that's that's because
uh Spar are atom q and you know they're
they're documented to you know behave
exactly the same as the corresponding
ordinary that's why Sanders's comment
about Matrix as a rapper which is what
you're going to as well with the whole
you know type but but it's going to have
more is going to be more like graph that
in you know and that also affects things
when you have real you know when matri
represents real data you might want to
have more annotations around them you
might want to know that the third column
is your temperatures I know but that's
what we've done with data
set that's what we're doing with with
data and you need you want other things
you want to highlight a column a
row sub but I I
just we're going to get all that and I
have a plan to get it think form is the
way to get it okay let's not talk about
it right now I don't think it we're
we're you know we're six months early
yeah at least um all right what do we
what do we need to look at here and this
is
basically fine that's kind of cool to
clear away to show the result of QR DEC
composition okay interval
can they deal with a round as
well no
nope
ouch what's it going to take to be able
to deal with the round in linear
algebra well it's possible that it works
if arithmetic Works in a round it could
work
uh basically the naive you know the the
schoolbook algorithm is just rational
and operations work actually probably
yeah yeah the thing is whether whether
they the result has correct statistical
meaning of of of the of the error in the
around which no I mean it won't because
just as you know and and so so one of
the problems with both of these is the
dependence
problem yes um and so both centered
interval and the statistical interval
like around
treats things as independent and that
means that's at least
amusing it's not
horrible I mean look at the size of the
errors
though
yeah and so actually I meant to ask that
so that that that the way that these
linear algebra operations are
implemented if it's just naively
implemented with intervals they will
have much larger intervals than if
specific choices algorithmic choices are
made that mitigates the growth of
intervals let's hope they're tight
intervals coming out are they I I don't
think that they're tight they but
they're for sure in closing the question
is yeah so they they guarantee enclosure
which is more than we get with bignes
for
instance
okay but do they in fact puff out a lot
or
not uh it really depends on the
operation in inverse actually doesn't
seem
so still a little bit yes they are
losing uh
Precision which which is correct I mean
if you work with big news you get the
same Precision you started with and it's
it's not
correct interesting well maybe we should
fix that no that was an explicit
choice to make them fix
precision and not very wait a second so
if if you have in a matrix you have 20
digigit Precision numbers and you invert
The
Matrix what do you get out
now
I think it's it it will say would you
you check what the Precision is of the
Matrix that's the Precision that's set
and when you get it out it's going to be
20 you know same
Precision I
see and is that correct or I mean is
that under what cumstances choice it's a
it's a
choice
because what is it assuming about the
independence of the
elements
well it's it's actually doing fix fixed
Precision computation so so it doesn't
doesn't track the errors during
computation I understand the
implementation but I'm asking
theoretically if I do in Matrix inverse
MH then is it not the case that I'm just
not thinking clearly about this and it
relates to the around qu case as
well the around case we're assuming
every error is
uncorrelated yeah in intervals you know
individual operations assume step too
yeah the difference is you know in the
around you do the average case error in
the centered you do the worst case
error I understand but but okay okay is
there a clear right answer in both the
interval case and the around case for
the Matrix inverse or is it something
which depends on one's assumptions about
independent of Matrix elements no there
is there is a definite tightest possible
but I don't know of any algorithm that
can achieve
it I see you know I think that there's
been some study of for some particular
families or matrices where they can
compute it and to show sort of as
benchmarks to see Benchmark against
other algorithms that are practical
algorithms and see how how bad off or
not bad off they are
yeah yeah I understand I mean this is
you know all we've ever been able to do
in um uh you know in arbitrary Precision
arithmetic is to not you know come up
with digits that are fake so to speak we
can't guarantee that we give you all the
digits that we might conceivably give
you other words we might have an
algorithm that in principle in this
computation there's a way of uniquely
determining 20 digits but our actual
algorithm only gets 15 well that too but
the sign ific
arithmetic has failure cases it's not
like interval arithmetic you know
particularly with low Precision the
singularities in that model but um but
when you have high Precision it's really
good I mean it's like super
good and and not if you have high
precision and not so much error it's
super
good
right all right well anyway I think we
understand this so far but I I do think
that I mean can somebody please
inventory whether around works with all
of these different Matrix
operations yeah and then let's ask the
question um and we should probably some
put examples in there but but I mean ask
the question which Matrix operations are
you not supporting with
interpals all the well well I'm sure I'm
sure a lot of
the you know like so all the other
operations will just work with
you know they will work with intervals
but but it's hard to tell whether
whether they're getting correct
enclosure they'll just treat intervals
as arbitrary
objects right yeah so so so how do we
indicate when we get the right answer
and when we don't get the right
answer other than by looking at the
documentation and saying that seeing
that this function supports intervals if
if it doesn't say that then
doesn't um I right and I was going to
say that you know things that don't
really have symbolic algorith right my
guess is that you know the the around is
going through the symbolic code so uh
right so you know any function which
doesn't have symbolic algorithms is is
going to to
die right and function that does have
symbolic algorithm might do something
which is incorrect in terms of you know
working with
around why how could it do something
incorrect uh like assume everything is
uncorrelated but if you if you divide a
by a you may get in in the case of round
you will get something with should get
something with the error but the Matrix
if you do for instance row reduce you
will get exact ones on the on the
diagonal I know but you'll never get the
wrong answer right you'll always just
get an answer that is right unless
somebody is for you know forcing the
exact ones on the DI pivot columns right
exactly because they assume that you
know division produces an exact
canellation yeah I understand so that
okay well for goodness sake we should
take a look at this all right let's
continue so the other thing just since
we're talking about around centered
interval so we are we have been flowing
or we are flowing in so we have
obviously special function evaluations
for around because it's just based on a
on a series truncated
series um we likewise have Matrix
functions so we have element wise which
is the listability but we also have
Matrix functions which we're going to
flow in which also have for all the
special
functions what do you mean we have what
you mean Matrix functions you mean I
mean we have fun Matrix function
function exactly so you can have a
matrix I see that's nice hyp geometric
pfq because of that yeah it's
amusing let's hope well the special
functions people wrote a bunch of books
on Matrix functions of okay all right G
and you know it'll be that's
good all right should we move
on okay so have we covered everything we
have not covered everything everything
here we looked at nline integrate yes
yes and surface
integrate
okay I think we were we had some trouble
here didn't we yeah and uh I can give a
bit of background if that's okay yeah
the background this that we have been
trying for some time to see whether we
can actually put models into our
calculus function rather than equations
or other input algebre now question how
do you do it um which way to control
system which is the one place where we
actually have a very close uh
relationship with d solve Etc in fact
they actually use uh functionality quite
a lot probably the only part of system
that does it so systematically um so
then the question is um can we look at
their things like in a state response
output response and try and access them
from within let's say dool or desolve
value and we tried the equation based
approach um so subar had shown us how to
get the equations from the state model
it looked pretty much uh redundant
because as far as I get it I I
understand I I want to know about the
syntax here the syntax is very simple
you have you have a instead of having
equation you have a state based model
right and then you have an input you
need an input for that to happen Okay so
in this case s t that's that's a s and
it's do look look this input is a mess
relative to the standard dies input it's
just a mess I mean it's just a mess the
fact we have string thing right so let's
try and clean it up yeah okay sure all
right so let's
understand what is a state space model
what is that okay so that
is
um what is going on here why is this
taking forever I don't know doesn't make
any sense to me unless a b and c okay I
don't really know why it took time try
it again well probably loading something
yeah but if it's loading it should tell
us let's please start having progress
monitors these things that are slow I
don't think okay but that's a whole new
thing like loading packages like no
startup packages have progress monitor
loud know I know that I know that but I
think we should inventory which ones are
slow because I I'm surprised this is so
slow yeah me too okay so go ahead
actually probably the easiest is to go
to state space model reference page
because I'm going to try to say in words
what it's on there open it up now this
is a slightly old page need some
modernization but explain it see the
um there are many kinds of syntaxes but
you see the basic representation in the
paragraph that you're pointing to X is a
vector X Prime T equals
a.x plus b do U and U is called the
input so that's that's what you would
call a forcing function then there's
another equation which is the output
equation Y output equals you know C dox
plus
d.u so it depends on State and
input and this thing just has by
convention
ABCDE
yes
spof okay but State space model there
represents this equation
here yeah so it has it has more extended
forms that's a d there okay okay how do
I get out the actual equation for that
so that's not documented but we can
bring it up in the next design review we
do control so it's not for this group to
to fix it I know but I want to see
roughly how it
works call in subba here right now yeah
let's do it let's do it nobody can do
that please
I mean is it like I type equations here
or something probably no well he showed
me a long way which he actually sent me
a not notebook I mean it's not official
it's not official no I I realize that I
understand that it's got to have a it's
got to have a dependent and independent
variable that it's got to specify
because this thing is a
disembodied you know kind of equation by
you know hung up by its
coefficients yeah exactly right which is
all well and good and a thing that
indeed deserves to be and desolve it's
just a question of what an earth the
actal syntax looks like
Fair yes yes absolutely
yes all right so anyways one of those
systems with an input is a completely
specified system of differential and
algebraic
equations
yes
I understand I mean I understand this is
a I mean in principle we could go from a
state space model
to I mean if if we say desolve
value I
see
I
see and the the first by the way just
you said that the input to desolve is
clean I don't think so it's like a soup
of of equations and initial and boundary
conditions I understand I understand but
I mean it's it's okay the scoping of
variables is if not perfect at least
reasonable uh absolutely
yes okay but
here I just Haven a freaking clue what's
going on and I we need sub to talk about
sub values of State space
model I don't get this I don't
understand this I understand that there
are different ways to use the state
space model but I don't think this
belongs Outside Inside the
desolve let's keep going and we'll come
back to this as sub sure yes so then we
have uh yeah that's the same time I
think we get honestly I'm happy to even
get dool value you know so difference
equations and differential equations are
both
used difference equations for digital
systems right differential equations for
analog let's look at this do solve M
equations yeah uh this these are just
improvements for the book by Pani which
is next Target after Kam this is a
modern version of poan much of Kam much
more much deeper
so we trying to absorb it bit by bit
this is the record part over here which
reduces to second order linear
basically so that's kind of classical D
solve so this is Ser in order for the
workflow when we return typically
infinite sums for like PD you know if
you do separation by you know separation
of variabl this is like series for sums
or or Precision for
sums yes yes sort yes kind of sort
of what about
products so we thought about but it
didn't I looked at what we around and
products seem to be infinitely smaller
and us and trunk we could have a
truncate product I have no problem but I
just couldn't justify it based on what
I'm I'm not completely buying I mean
like you can presumably truncate
differently in the positive and negative
yes but we document that how we do it I
mean what's useful yeah we we we
document every single piece that's uh
actually being
done and is there not a better model for
this a simpler case way of doing that so
what we had is like there there's like
just one super simple thing which is
like a number type or
nothing um and then there is a detail
case which is a an
association
okay I don't know I mean it's it's not
it's it's not unreasonable at
least you know what I'm saying that that
that spec there of sort of control more
and more details yeah I agree I mean I
don't know about this activation
inactivate I see because the point is
activate semi automatic will just go
from
you know presumably it will go from
activate inactivated to
inactivated am I making sense it will go
from inactive to act to
activated so so it will evaluate okay I
mean it's not totally obvious I guess
that's the right thing to do by the well
if you want to plot it for let say right
yeah okay so this is a typical use case
you want to plot sort of a truncated
solution to a pde or igen you know
differential igen problem
then yeah you want see indefinite
sum uh what what do we do with those I
mean I don't know because you mean you
won't truncate that but there's no thing
to truncate right there's well there is
implicitly I mean it's kind of like
adding limits to the sum adding limits
to the integral that's an implicit
truncation like
operation we could do that I mean you
got to assume some kind of assumption
about a lower limit upper limit
something I don't know something of that
so yeah it's not it's kind of messy it
it it I think this we typically don't
touch indefinite things for that reason
I mean I'm not saying we should not do B
I'm just
saying so this well beyond what we need
but it seems to have I think this is
nice I think we should thank you great
great
um I think is there anything other than
summon product
that could get
this well I think it's pretty far out
but continued fraction K would be yeah I
know I know that's but I think it's like
so far out the tail
yeah um
okay and we have the bilateral hyper
geometric which is basically the
bilateral version Oh laas conall first
so I think we just talked a little bit
last time and there are three opt we
need this because it's been people get
confused a lot between different kind of
convolution and they're looking for this
kind of convolution they look at convol
gives the wrong results but something
I'm sure you have you know seen this a
million times Stephen a domain or
Community use a convention which they
document and they use the same words to
describe it like
convolution yeah and La PL transform is
a good one and in one Community it's
bilateral everything in another
Community is unilateral everything so
the the the signal processing Community
is bilateral everything the control
Community is unilateral everything okay
it's just same names just it's different
meanings and we found I mean that's what
we found with foro transforms too right
like every Community had their own
indeed definition but we were there we
parameterized it right yes
yes uh but that I mean that itself is
really hard to document and this
particular case honestly this is what
people most often want the convolution I
mean I hav rarely seen anyone actually
want the so this is one-sided
convolution is that correct yes yes it's
yes it goes from zero one sided or
unilateral or causal those are three you
think kind of greens function kind of
you're convolving to get the state at
time the solution I don't think M plus
should be a no I'm I'm happy to have it
causal unilateral water works for you
one-sided convolve one-sided weal if we
if we call since we called the other
ones bilateral I think we shouldn't sort
of mix two what do we call bilateral
bilateral laas transform and bilateral Z
transform I see so this would then be
unilateral convolve that's fine then
absolutely no problem I think it's much
better than llast convolve which
confuses me to llast transforms and go I
mean it's related but it's not it's not
the same no I think it just restricts
the use unnecessarily so we can change
into convolve no problem at
all okay hey excuse me this is subba did
you need me here yes we do okay uh
Stephen can you take couple minutes and
look at you want look at pfq later on
it's fine with me by the way it's a
bilateral pfq we can come to
later let's just look at that for a
second if it's really fast it's very
fast there's nothing over there really
we trying to complete out of pfu we did
APPL last time there's one last thing
which is the bilateral we just talk
about bilateral so B pfq is basically
the W infinite version of pfq it's got a
very narrow range of uh convergence like
you basically unit circle you think of
positive frequency negative frequency
the two will converge only if uh yeah on
a very so but this is kind of the Very
extreme case which we missing and we've
done it now that's all but it's nice
because yeah that's
all
um unilateral bilateral
do we I mean I don't know do we have
stuff with wavelets that had this issue
as
well or do I Mis
remember I'm gonna go check I
just I'm just wondering
what I mean it just reminds me of all
these you
know
bilateral commissions and listen that
I don't know relations yeah yeah
bilateral filter
here
um no so we had
biorthogonal what the hell does that
mean well there's a biorthogonal spline
wavelength that's just like special
wavelet yeah okay Sandra is asking on
our live stream about multiple sums and
I realize I don't completely understand
that so when you say trans truncate sum
of exper what in Earth does it default
to each of the iterate you know if you
have a multivariate sum let's say three
summation signs it's it truncates each
one to that number okay but but this
doesn't have a number and I don't think
that should be a
default what would the default be now
that's crazy I'm sorry this is crazy you
cannot have a default of
five just give the freaking number is it
five because we have five fingers what
what why no no I think Roger's point is
that we should have a default which
people don't need to specify but we can
just take that away we don't document it
that no no I mean the multi didn't you
switch topic right now I did we're back
to truncate sum for oh yes didn't you
say truncate multiple sums that's what I
was ask but I I I'm now I've realized
that I should have looked at this more
carefully because this is crazy in my
opinion but it's a like I we we happy
not it's a little bit like when you do N
I know I know I was going to give that
exact analogy how about don't do that
initially that's okay yeah no problem I
just am not convinced it's okay Stephen
I was a little bit uncomfortable with it
two yeah fine all right now let's look
talk about double sums presumably this
could be a list five five or something
or it could be just a single five in
which case it means all the indices go
up to five do we
agree we we haven't done that because
this is is typically an expression with
potentially many sums in
it okay well then in that case if you
give a single number yeah you say
truncate this comma five it just means
that every one of the sums goes up to
five yes exactly what it means okay fine
but what I'm suggesting is that if you
wanted to have different numbers in
different uh Dimensions so to speak we
could probably support that so that it
would be sort of um you know like two
three would be sort of two exactly then
we need to sort of say order what the
hell does that mean so what happens if
the outer order yeah order inner what
the oh yeah well that is a good question
but so the answer is the order should be
the same imagine you're making a table
no imagine you're making an
array okay imagine this is an array M
right you say
array uh s i j well sign has 1
H2 comma
23 whatever order that this is a stupid
case because I should have done just a
list the F of hash one and hash two I
didn't even need the F okay so whatever
that
does okay see what I'm saying yeah is
what it should do in my opinion yeah and
actually by the way we had an earlier
very bad syntax was like you know for
each iterator but that looked really
messy so we abandoned it but this
definitely worth doing I think yeah so
so we take away the default that one
without the second argument and we add
the multi the ve that both both are okay
very reasonable we'll do
that
okay so what happens if the limits are
dependent on one of the
variables right I I mean I think let's
think about that then then this becomes
a cookie cutter that might be where the
cookie might be smaller than the cookie
cutter yeah right I I think I mean we've
we can play on that but the whole point
was to give something
that's that that kind of solves this
problem which you're having all the time
we need to go forward with for year
series other things and we you we can
take up things like what is saying
but we have other you understand what
the replacement it needs to be
basically
uh Max Sor of Min n comma and that the
the the sort of Max number you
gave okay but do you understand my
analogy yeah yeah I understand what
you're saying but but I'm just want to
check with I can check that separately
that our implementation actually does it
oh I see I see okay fine that's separate
yeah I don't know what the heck total
terms does I mean I I think
these probably we should not do that at
this point that's I think it's better to
keep it
simpler do we have another option we
could reuse for this activation
thing no are you sure well if you said
activate that would be the natural but
then we have a function called
activate no but I know but don't do we
have something like activated Arrow true
or false no I not seen
that so unfortunately activate is the
most natural thing you know here act
what
activated activated I see you need a new
option for that this well I'm thinking I
I don't know I mean maybe we can add
that in some other places as
well like like for example we could do
integrate yeah you know or or you know
when we do an
integrate and we produce the
sum we currently produce an inactivated
sum is that
correct dep or is it an activated sum I
don't
know that I don't think integrate ever
returns a sum not yet and desolve
sometimes return Astic will return a sum
dool return a sum integral sorry are
they okay either way but are they
activated or inactivated sums and
integrals um it's a choice but uh
generically they'll be inactive because
they're too hard how do you make the
choice we make the choice very simple
that we try the indefinite integral if
it looks like it can be done we do it
otherwise you might very well wait wait
for a few hundred seconds for the
definite one to give up no wait a second
when you say it's a choice does the user
have a choice to just say always give me
the inactivated
version no but that's actually something
that been asked but that's that's a good
point Ste right so why don't we just
have an option called you know activated
results or
activated see what I'm saying and just
put it into all these
functions is it for 40 no you want
you you decide you decide no no I mean
like diesel testing alone would take a
month so yeah okay fine yeah all right
but let's just come up with the design
though sure I mean I'm not quite sure
that activated is the right thing
because that suggests it's not clear
that it's the result that's
activated
yeah
um so diesel can return inactive
integrals and in active
sums basically yes at this
point and I think in the future
integrate will probably also possibly
return inactive
sums okay so I
mean activated result Arrow true or
false or automatic yeah yes or possibly
some Association which gives which what
to do with particular functions yes so
we had an interesting case that diesel
got sped up some huge
Factor uh when we uh stopped activating
the integrals because a lot of failure
cases was trying to do the integrals yes
and so literally all of the performance
problems that people had complained
about went
away so it's not always a good thing you
know what I'm saying to be be active
yeah no I
realize
so activated result activate result
activated result I think activate result
sounds like you know it's like what
they're telling us to do or not
do which this one here activate result
yeah just like what what they are I
don't I agree I don't think that's bad
Roger what do you think I think it looks
good cuz I can see
us I can see um us doing it more I mean
these been at the frontier of this but I
agree I mean this is this is very
similar to the Target structure type
thing it's returning something which is
not quite
digested right I mean I think inactive
has in independent
value uh because sometimes you want to
see the formal structure of things very
useful mhm
so okay like yeah like when people do
you know separation of variables it
comes out as a sum that's what you
learn you know it should
be
right um Sandra is asking what if you
have a nested sum and you only want to
truncate the first level of the sum well
the answer is you say truncate blah blah
blah list one yes yes after what we
discuss right now yes I think what we
should say but the only thing we should
do is we should say truncate sum blah
blah blah blah blah list one let's say
you say if you just want to unravel one
of the
sums you should say either Infinity
comma five comma you know what I'm
saying what what should be the thing
that is the one that says Don't unravel
this
automatic
no
no Infinity is fine as well I mean well
I'm not sure Infinity is right maybe it
should be because because in this case
you've got sums here that
are I mean full might be a
possibility
all wall is the right
thing all is the right thing okay
yep okay so just so just one last
clarification I know we could ask R so
do you still want the association you'd
rather not have them keep it experiment
or keep it experimental was release this
function until we got the option done I
mean we can keep it well we can get this
option for this function the activated
result for activate result for this
function we can get that okay fine yeah
okay I would just punt the association I
would just you can put it in if you want
as an undocumented thing but I would
just punt it I just don't think it's
that useful yeah I honestly it was since
we skipped total terms
and we
elaborated we um the activate some is
now a new Option yeah there's nothing
left actually yeah it's all gone okay
hey Sandra suggests another thing which
is a sparse representation for the um uh
this case here where you could say
something like two
arrow4 I see is not bad yeah it's not
bad do you we talk about it later Dand
yeah sure sure we can we can do that
yeah one thing that I worry about one
day which we don't have right now is
maybe maybe it just isn't a thing is
sort of the D dimensional summation
where D is a variable where it's just
like sum infinitely
over we we always explicitly Nest the
sums yeah we we slowly coming back to
sort of the discret calculus side and
multivaried sums and the language
anguage of multivariat sums is very much
on
it and and summation over regions which
this kind of is right you
know well just so long as this truncate
sum doesn't blow up something with with
the summation of
regions because I guess what you want to
do is truncate some comma a
region
yeah but I think that you know the way
you can see truncate s is kind of like
intersect the region you sum over with
this re linear thing
exactly yeah that's what I was thinking
I mean that truncate sum could then take
as a region specification maybe a pure
function that says you know hash one
between this and this and you know
some eventually so when we I think when
when we do summation of a region we
should overhaul this to also take that
specification I
agree I agree we don't yet have discrete
regions though no and I I don't think
we'll explicitly have them but we will
have an interpretation of them so what
we think is an intersection with a real
region and a
lattice but we we'll come to that we
have we we haven't really worked it
through just bits and
pieces okay sand is asking the actual
you know should you be able to give the
actual index in truncate sum I think not
because of scoping yeah we had that
discussion and that's that's exactly my
answer you know too uh because what if
you have what if you have a big
expression and there are two eyes that
are summation indices which one did you
mean yeah
right and sum of sums if the if the
truncate sum is a sum of a of a you know
how does that work if you you've got a
sum of sums and one of them is a
univariate sum and it does doesn't have
a second layer sum in it words truncate
sum can take any expression can it
not
yes and there can be many sums inside of
it right so it's like n it goes in and
and reduces the Precision of every
effectively of every sums yes yes so it
should just ignore the semantics should
presumably be if it asks for a summation
over you know restricting a variable
where a variable where isn't such a
variable it should just ignore it yes
okay right let's return to the the thing
we were talking about earlier which was
the state space
business okay sub how do I get from this
state space model how do I get it its
differential equation oh okay um that's
an internal
symbol that's not
good okay but tell me how to do it
okay it's
um okay I'll put it in the
chat it's that symbol and wrap a wrap
State space model around
it that's horrifying well I mean it's
yeah well I guess it's horrifying both
as an internal name but what do you mean
is that is that an argument to State
space model no it's that's the function
that acts on States yeah then you give
the state space model
insight and what variables is going to
pick uh it'll default
variables so the so the first argument
the first argument of the first argument
is the differential
equations okay and the other ones are
the independent variables and some weird
yeah the independent variables well
that's exactly why we have formal
variables right it's using the standard
names as formal variables
yeah so if you give those variables in
within the state space model then it'll
choose those so after d if you give X
I'm sorry I'm just a much simpler
problem why are these lists of lists why
is it not just a single list of
dependent variables no because they're
very different character there's a state
variables which are the
actual uh in dependent variables then
they're input variables they use then
they're output variables but so how do I
feed this to
dool well if you if you feed it these I
mean dool will not do very well on these
mixed differential and algebraic
equations okay but what does the syntax
mean I mean in other words for do solve
it has a syntax equation inde dependent
variable independent variable no no I
mean you could get it there it's just
that youu you you've already substituted
with sinusoid right so you need to
replace U1 t with s of t or whatever it
was in the example can't remember yeah
okay but is there a version of desolve
that can eat this in this output here no
no we had actually lists is all all all
sort of you
know you can have any mix of lists of
equations and it will just flatten it
all out and it no I understand that but
I'm okay so can't you just apply desolve
to that or do we have too many lists no
can we can't do it because the structure
of those input output whatever things is
more specific yeah yeah so we we'll have
to actually sub asist say substitute for
the U and then use then we also have to
add the initial conditions and then we
can then we have to invoke desolve value
on the first argument so the first the
first part of the first argum of the
first argument of the first result now
the first part of the first part is the
equations and the second part are the
values that we're interested the output
the output variables okay so what I'm
trying to understand is we're trying to
feed State space model into desolve
value yes and it's a total mess here
because it would be one thing if you
know State Sur model so one of the
things here's one thing to be aware of
though diesel value let's say that you
have five differential
equations but I only really want to look
at the third variable so I can have that
as the second argument so diesel value
doesn't have to return all
solution variables right in fact you
know one of the examples I use is right
you know what get the list Y and Y Prime
and plot the solution in Phase space yes
right so right it it can be an arbitary
expression in the dependent and
independent variables yes that's that's
a feature of diesel value Stephen that
the second argument specify what is it
that I actually want to look at the
understand understand but you're hacker
rating this because that sinx is a ha I
still hacker rated to some extent right
because the so the only question is we
could make it less hacky if we created a
new container that says connect this
sinusoid to the input can I make a
suggestion why not give dool value an
association as its first argument yeah
and then just
have you know for the subsequent
arguments yeah
right you're going to have to give a t
yeah somehow if there's an association
for the first argument don't give the
second argument so two argument dool
value I'm thinking I mean maybe I'm not
sure about what the heck is that s t
doing there but that's a question you
could ask about any D input right it's
only you and I who know that something
initial condition something is not no no
no no no no no no the the
desolve normally has a collection of equ
equations here s t is not an equation
what the heck is it sometimes you have V
event and right yes it's an implicity
equation right it's input uh it's the
the the input function equals equals s
of t i of t equal to s t basically yeah
but but what I'd prefer to see is if
State space model could be a subv value
with s of t or something something like
that because that's basically
specializing the state space model to
have U of T or something b equal sign of
T is that not
correct yes yes it's saying that the
input is now specific right so why is
that a sub value of State space model
not some random weird oh no no I see
what you're saying that my sub value you
mean applying State space model to S of
T for example yes I mean is that a bad
idea I'm
thinking that is probably a bad idea
because State space model may need
different uh number of
inputs that too yeah it can take Vector
inputs for
sure um needs a list
then but the form that is right now it's
just not going to cut it no I I don't
disagree Stephen okay but I I think that
we
um but we don't also want we don't want
a super heavy form like it could be a
bigo
which but it's a bit heavy then no it's
it's too heavy but the fact is that this
is incomprehensible so I mean for
example and
um well here's a
possibility okay which may or may not
make
sense State space
model no I mean this is crazy okay space
state state space
model basically stands for when it
appears in D Sol value basically stands
for this first argument here that make
sense and then the second argument is an
association that has to anonymously
refer to the X U and Y values here
because we don't want to have to name
them that's the whole point of using
State space model is we don't have to go
and pedantically name all the variables
yes so okay so what would it look like
if that's what we did if State space
model
represents the equations effectively
yes and then we have to say how we knit
together different pieces and then we
give the independent variable T last and
then the result that we get is simply a
function of T which is correct
yes okay so what would be the second
argument to make right so could could we
then we've Le before so we tried
everything so could the sign go along
with the output response
well I mean I'm what I'm suggesting is
that what this looks like
is you know dool value of this is just a
single thing comma so you know
Association I don't think we ever should
have state
response I mean if you want that make
another state space model without an
output I don't I don't understand enough
State space models to discuss that but
what I'm saying here is whatever
knitting you need to say what the U of
is what is U what is that what is the
name of that
thing it's like the input yeah the input
signal okay well I don't know if it's a
signal but I mean in input I mean the
weird thing is is that right you're
specifying you're using the second
argument which is normally the return
thing to return to specify things about
the input which is well that's
bad it's okay for dool Value because
sometimes you might say y of T the whole
Square so I mean I I kind this is
exactly what was holding us back that
really the first argument of D value is
supposed to contain all the information
need to solve I mean would it would it
would would you be happier if we took
the current syntax but just instead of s
of T it was the string input equals sine
of T then we have an equation yeah
that's fine we can do that well I'm not
sure it's right though I mean but then
what's the second argument
there's no freaking variable we don't
know what variable we're solving for
because the variable has been all
lighted yes but we don't need it
right I know we don't need it but we we
we don't need it but what are we going
to do with the second argument leave it
out or what well because you have either
have output or state or there are three
other conveniences there's
ramp um impulse and step respon these
are kind of important special cases of
output response which we are now
supporting so there are five of them so
there two there two things then so the
second argument could be a string yes
that says what it is you're extracting
yes okay or maybe a list of strings now
the question is how do you qualify the
first
argument with its additional information
which is basically here the input
correct yes okay so what I would argue
is I mean okay look if it's really just
one thing like this okay I mean maybe
this is a horrifying idea but what about
the possibility of
this and this is now what would this be
called this would be called well what
are the possibilities for
this what are the possibilities for what
you are generating as output please
sorry okay so there are okay there's
State response output response ramp
response okay okay fine so so State
response is a definite output yes that's
like a definite function that you might
call that you might want to ex of a name
named part that you want out and and we
used formulas before because we had
variables so we could use formulas okay
so what about this form
here I'm I'm fine with that I think it
it's clear
enough but so long as it's on some level
I feel like I mean maybe too obscure but
I feel like since s of T is on the is
the input it should be on the left hand
side I think so too that's what I
thought oh yeah that's correct that's a
good point yeah or flip the arrow around
yeah you're flipping yeah I mean you're
well I think let's not flip the arrow
let's not flip the
arrow yeah is there a default for the
sign of
T well I think that the most important
thing that people always look at is Step
unit step
okay so that could be a default yeah
okay this is a little
weird take a think about this I I think
this is a this seems it's better than we
had before but it's still a little weird
it is a little
weird uh I but it's not I mean what you
this is better than what we had so I'm
I'm I feel better about this yeah I mean
this is explainable the first thing is
the
equation that is specified in terms of a
state space model the second thing is
what the output is and the third thing
is the independent variable
yes and I like the idea of that Arrow
because it says that you're kind of
feeding that input into the state Spas
model yeah well okay
let's try it out all right we got to go
to another live stream here guys I don't
know what whether some of you are in it
but I need to go to it at least we're
really late for it I am yeah okay thank
you Stephen all right thank you okay see
you guys soon bye bye
bye